[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 nous sommes le jeudi 31
janvier tout de suite les titres de
cette édition
il doit entrer en vigueur dans deux mois
le bric site se fera t-il avec ou sans
accord des incertitudes qui inquiète les
plus de 100 entreprises yvelinoise
travaillant avec le royaume uni pour les
informer une réunion était organisée
cette semaine à la chambre de commerce
et d'industrie des yvelines jusqu'au 23
février le recensement est lancée il
permet de compter le nombre d'habitants
d'une ville action importante pour
anticiper les besoins en services et
équipements publics un acte civique et
surtout obligatoire aux yeux de la loi
on vous explique tout dans cette édition
et puis le dernier volet de notre
dossier de la rédaction consacrée à la
solidarité sur le territoire ce soir
nous partons en maraude avec les
bénévoles de la croix rouge de saint
quentin en yvelines des sorties
primordial auprès des sans abri en cette
période de grand froid et sur ce plateau
également nous parlerons de la caravane
citoyenne de passage ce week end à la
verrière et aussi de l'association
roumaine safe mise en lumière le
week-end dernier dans l'émission qui
veut gagner des millions
sitôt parti qu'elle est déjà de retour
la neige est tombée à nouveau cet après
midi dans les yvelines météo france a
placé le département en alerte orange
jusqu'à demain matin 6h 3 à 5 cm de
précipitations sont attendues jusqu'à 8
cm localement un redoux significatif est
toutefois annoncée pour la nuit
prochaine avec des températures entre 2
et 5 degrés est les conditions de
circulation pourraient devenir difficile
selon météo france il est recommandé
dans la mesure du possible de différer
vos déplacements en voiture et de
privilégier les transports en commun se
préparer sans savoir le 30 mars prochain
le bric site entrera en vigueur mais
aujourd'hui encore les termes de cette
sortie de la grande-bretagne la grande
bretagne de l'union européenne elles ne
sont pas connus pour accompagner au
mieux les entreprises yvelinoise
concernés une réunion se tenait à la cci
de versailles cette semaine les
précisions avec ce sujet de mélanie poké
les images de patrick jacques de dixmude
à accompagner s'informer malgré le flou
à deux mois de l'entrée en vigueur du
bric site les entreprises s'interrogent
sur le futur
besoin de savoir où je vais mettre les
pieds comme l'angleterre mais
fournisseurs en angleterre n'en savent
pas plus que moi je viens prendre un peu
la température du côté de
l'administration française et connaître
mes obligations et devoirs
au coeur de cette réunion le scénario le
plus compliqué hendrix it sans accord le
royaume uni deviendrait un pays tiers
l'angleterre devient un pays sur lequel
il n'y a plus aucun n'accord donc on
repart sur une page blanche tant est que
nous n'avons aucun accord pour avoir des
accords équivalents à ceux que nous
avons avec certains privés pays
privilégiés comme la norvège ou la
suisse où les états unis vont nous
demander au minimum dix ans de travail
pour arriver à mettre en place un
certain nombre d'accords il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises innovantes qui font du
commerce avec le royaume uni parce que
c'est un partenaire privilégié d'un
point de vue économique mais jusqu'à
présent elle ne faisait pas forcément de
grand export elle faisait de l'intra
communautaire c'est à dire qu'elle
n'était pas soumise aux règles de douane
dans les yvelines
elles sont plus d'une centaine notamment
des petites entreprises à être concernés
par ces échanges intracommunautaires si
aucun accord n'est trouvé les droits de
douane seront rétablis ces entreprises
vont devoir apprendre un métier vous
faire faire cette prestation par un
professionnel de la douane et donc elles
doivent c'est celle ci qui sont le plus
impacté par le break site puisque celles
qui font déjà de l'import et l'export
en réalité ça sera un peu plus dans leur
portefeuille export ou encore le coeur
de cible des douanes les entreprises
exportant télé pme avec un mot clé
l'anticipation il reste deux mois avant
la mise en place du bric site economy
toujours au généreux concours le centre
commercial parly ii a inauguré ce matin
le premier site espot mercedes benz en
europe le concept 6 vendeurs feront
découvrir aux clients
l'univers de la marque à travers de la
réalité virtuelle et des écrans reliés à
des tablettes et des véhicules équipés
de technologies électriques sont
également présentés certains pourront
être testés et directement sur le
parking du centre les réactions au micro
de michael et demi d'euros par les deux
c'est un centre commercial avec plus que
ans menu en visiteurs par an en plus il
attire le contre masiala attire une
clientèle de qualité
et c'est aussi parler d'eux c'est don
entre dans notre chalandise de
mercedes-benz paris donc on aime
vraiment être pionnier c'est vraiment la
diane du centre est pionnier ouvrir les
derniers concepts les dernières modes
les dernières tendances et c'est
vraiment ce qu'on a fait aujourd'hui
avec mercedes benz france
le chesnay et rocquencourt qui forment
depuis un mois une seule et même comme
une nouvelle ce soir les le nom de ses
habitants restent à déterminer et reste
à déterminer le nom des habitants du
chéné rocancourt ce soir les élus de la
commune se réunissent pour choisir le
nom de ses habitants premier point
inscrit à l'ordre du jour selon toute
vraisemblance il devrait s'appeler les
chaînés courtois séance du conseil
municipal à 20h45
elle sillonne les yvelines pour vous
inciter à voter après versailles et
elancourt la caravane citoyenne sera de
passage à la verrière ce week-end
bonsoir pierre lux bonsoir vous êtes le
référent départemental de la république
en marche cette action a été lancée par
votre parti l'objectif pour cette
caravane citoyenne qu'elle est il exclu
c'est d'inciter à voter d'un site à
voter pour la république en marche
c'est essentiellement une action
citoyenne qui vise à inciter les
personnes les citoyens parfois un peu
éloigné de la république à s'en
rapprocher à s'inscrire tout d'abord sur
les listes électorales et une réforme
assez importante en fait qui entre en
vigueur cette année qui leur permet de
s'inscrire à cette tardive manceau
listes électorales jusqu'au 31 mars
serait il atteint fin mars
effectivement et on va sur le terrain
pour aller leur expliquer pourquoi il
est important d'aller voter
ils peuvent le faire encore on les aide
à remplir les formulaires de
l'inscription ces listes électorales le
but est pas du tout d'aller leur dire
pourquoi voter ont fait pas de politique
on parle de l'actualité si les gens
veulent en parler mais on est vraiment
là pour rapprocher les gens de leur
citoyenneté et on précise que c'est ce
week end au cas là derrière au centre
commercial du bois de l'étang à partir
de 10h alors pourquoi elle est
nécessaire aujourd'hui cette action on
voit que les élections mobilisent peu il
y as souvent l'abstention qui gagne dans
les élections c'est pour ça que vous
allez auprès de ses habitants
tout à fait et en plus cette absence ans
elle est assez inégalement réparties
vous avez des territoires sur lequel
elle atteint des fois des scores très
importants beaucoup plus important que
les gens qui participent et nous on veut
vraiment aller voir ces personnes là
pour déjà savoir pourquoi est-ce
qu'elles ne vont pas voter
il ya souvent des leçons intéressantes
entier et ensuite pour les aider si
elles veulent faire ce qui reste là de
voter dans les démarches qui peuvent
parfois être un peu compliqué parce que
on n'a pas de centre administratif à
proximité où on a peur qu'il serait
compliqué donc on les aide mais on leur
parle on les aide on les écoute on dit
souvent que voter c'est un droit et un
devoir pourquoi il faut voter pourquoi
c'est un geste important c'est la
première expression de la citoyenneté
je pense que il est compliqué de
s'impliquer pleinement dans sa vie de
citoyen française s'en aller voter c'est
un geste fondateur dans notre république
c'est un droit qui a été acquis il ya
longtemps et qui maintenant en fait nous
permet de pleinement exprimer nos idées
mais si on prend l'exemple des
prochaines élections qui vont se tenir
en france le dimanche 26 mai prochain
pour les européennes on sait que c'est
un scrutin aussi qui rassemblent peu
moins de 43 % de participation aux
dernières élections en 2014
que dites-vous sur ces élections est ce
que vous parlez des élections
européennes avec cette caravane
citoyenne non on n'en parle pas c'est
pas fait pour ce n'est pas fait pour
après on répond aux questions si les
gens vous nous le monde quand est ce que
sont les prochaines élections ce genre
de choses beaucoup ne savent même pas
que les élections européennes cette
année mais l'idée n'est vraiment pas de
de vendre un programme ou quelque chose
comme ça c'est sûr on parle des
élections européennes l'enjeu qu'elle
est il poursuit c'est vrai qu'on connaît
assez peu finalement ce scrutin les
français le connaissent assez peu vous
venez de le dire que quel est l'enjeu
autour de ces européennes
l'enjeu
majeur surtout surtout cette année quand
il dira pourquoi parce qu'on fait face à
une montée des populismes très important
dans toute l'europe et des gares 2014
lauras nationale avait fait la majorité
des voix en france et l'objectif cette
année c'est de faire en sorte que ce ne
soit pas le cas
et au niveau européen que les partis
populistes ne monte pas plus et même
perdre du terrain
notre objectif il est vraiment de
sauvegarde et l'europe n'ont pas dans sa
version actuelle mais en une version qui
lui permettent de s'améliorer et
d'améliorer notre quotidien nous reste
une minute donc la caravane citoyenne ce
week-end à la derrière il y aura
d'autres rendez vous d'ici le 31 mars
oui bien sûr il ya les rendez vous alors
certains sont prévues d'autres sont à
prévoir
on c'est notre cinquième rendez vous
demain et on a commencé à sartrouville
vernouillet on a fait le quartier de
jussieu à versailles qui on va souvent
versailles comme une ville plutôt aisée
mais qui a aussi ses quartiers plus
populaires et où l'absence ont là aussi
est très forte les prochaines arrêt de
cette caravane citoyenne c'est donc ce
samedi au centre commercial du bois de
l'étang à la derrière et c'est à partir
de 10h merci pierre lui d'avoir été avec
nos référent départemental de la
république en marche et je précise que
vous avez jusqu'au 31 mars pour vous
inscrire sur les listes électorales
toutes les informations sur le lien et
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
bonsoir ordre aurélie rose est la
campagne 2010 9 du recensement a débuté
le 17 janvier dernier on en parle avec
vous la première question est toute
simple ça sert à quoi le recensement
alors l'objectif numéro un du
recensement c'est bien sûr de savoir
combien de personnes vivent en france
cela permet également de déterminer la
participation de l'état au budget des
communes à déterminer le nombre d'élus
au conseil municipal mais aussi par
exemple de prévoir d'ouvrir une crèche
une école ou bien de développer les
moyens de transport est ce que tout le
monde est concerné par recherche moment
grégory seuls 8 % de la population des
communes de plus de 10 mille habitants
sont recensées tous les ans sans pour
son 100% par contre des résidents de
communes de moins de 10000 habitants le
sont tous les cinq ans alors un exemple
concret à saint quentin en yvelines
si vous habitez dans les communes qui
s'affiche à l'écran bien vous êtes
peut-être concernés cette année tout
dépend évidemment de votre quartier en
revanche le recensement à l'avarié à la
verrière et coignières s'effectuera en
2020 2021 pour la commune de magny les
hameaux
mais concrètement comment ça marche le
recensement alors la mairie recrute
plusieurs agents recenseurs qui sont
identifiables grâce à cette carte
officielle tricolore que vous voyez à
l'écran ils viennent chez vous et vous
donne une notice avec des identifiants
pour répondre au questionnaire en ligne
alors pas de panique un bien sûr si vous
n'avez pas internet puisque les agents
vous remettront un questionnaire papier
qu'ils reviendront chercher quelques
jours après et puis nouveauté cette
année
eh bien il se peut également que vous ne
voyez personne a notamment si vous
habitez par exemple dans l'ain dans un
logement collectif à guyancourt ou bien
le trappeur dans le cadre d'une
expérimentation avec
également la ville de trappes en fait
l'aller l'agent recenseur ne passent
même plus voir les gens il relève les
noms sur les boîtes aux lettres
il dépose un document et les gens ont
quatre jours pour pouvoir se recenser
directement et une dernière chose en cas
de refus de participer au recensement
est bien on peut recevoir une mise en
demeure puis une amende de 38 euros
merci aurélie pour ces informations en
compagnie de manon varaldo vous avez
passé une soirée avec la croix rouge de
saint quentin en yvelines ces bénévoles
effectuent des maraudes il sillonne les
rues pour aller à la rencontre des sans
abri les orienter vers des hébergements
d'urgence action essentielle en cette
période de grand froid c'est le dernier
numéro de notre dossier de la semaine
sur la solidarité reportage vendredi
soir il est 20 heures et les bénévoles
de la croix rouge de saint quentin en
yvelines charge le camion pour effectuer
une maraude jusqu'à minuit on peut
répondre par rapport à une aide
vestimentaire alimentaire accès aux
soins à travers comment tout ce qui est
soins soins dentaires dentifrice brosse
à dents par exemple et autres besoins
demandé par la personne rencontrée
l'action sociale de la croix rouge
française de saint quentin en yvelines
englobe 31 bénévoles ce soir cinq sont
présents donc et l'oea n'a pas pris
l'udc dominique la roselyne ils viennent
en renfort du samusocial 78 de novembre
à mars
parmi eux il y as n'a fait des maraudes
depuis quatre ans elle est devenue chef
d'equipe il y a deux ans et demi ça
m'apporte la satisfaction de la
satisfaction dans la mesure où honnête
de les gens et quand on voit le travail
des personnes qui sont volontaires et
que et qui sans qu'ils arrivent à s'en
sortir qu'en mais malgré tout ça fait
vraiment ça fait du bien durant ces
opérations des liens se créent entre
bénéficiaires et bénévoles
nous avons nos habitués qu'ils sont dans
le secteur auprès de chez nous donc
notamment georges que
qui est un sdf depuis 17 ans on à la rue
donc on sait ce qui leur fait plaisir de
manger donc au lui par exemple jean chez
le chocolat au lait donc on ne sort
jamais sans chocolat au lait à chaque
maraude
il y en a est en contact avec la
régulation pour connaître les
différentes missions de la soirée en
cette période de grand froid l'unité
locale met en oeuvre des dispositifs
spécifiques pour des personnes vivant
dans la rue vers les hébergements
d'urgence comparé l'hôpital mignot au
service des urgences ce cas de personnes
qui nous attendait à tous les coups il
va falloir les amener à satory don chu
ce soir après avoir récupéré les deux
bénéficiaires aux urgences de l'hôpital
andré mignot du chesnay rocancourt
les bénévoles de la croix rouge les
emmène au chu le centre d'hébergement
d'urgence de satory à versailles d'un
rien messieux hockey bottine dit je te
laisse au var jean jé piste rappelle
quand on le quitte ok bon d'érection
montigné les bénévoles se rendent
disponibles et sont au plus près des
personnes rencontrées vivent dans la rue
à l'image de george à la rue depuis 17
ans les bénévoles de l'unité locale de
la croix rouge vont toujours lui rendre
visite
alors qu'elles ont fait une foule à la
gravette
les bénévoles répondent aux besoins
fondamentaux des personnes rencontrées
chocolat tu dois me comporte des
compotes bleuroy com georges 124
personnes sont suivies à l'échelle de
l'agglomération
[Musique]
on reste dans le domaine associatif ou
même safe mises en lumière dans la
dernier numéro de qui veut gagner des
millions sa marraine florence foresti et
le comédien et humoriste jonathan cohen
ont remporté pour l'association basée à
saint germain en laye 72 mille euros
pour en parler frédéric mart bonne foi
frédéric mart vous est la cofondatrice
et la directrice générale de women safe
l'association accueille et soigne
gratuitement les femmes et les enfants
victimes de tout type de violence
des gens un point sur l'historique de
l'association depuis combien de temps
existe t'elle cette association
l'association existe depuis 2014
on va dire qu'en 2015 on s'est rendu
compte qu'en prenant les femmes victimes
de violence 70% de ces femmes là nous
disait avoir été victimes ou témoins de
violences dans leur enfance
donc on a ouvert effectivement un pôle
jeunes on va dire jeunes enfants en 2000
17 c'est important de dire qu' on ne
peut pas effectivement mettre en lumière
une problématique et en oublier toute
une partie puisque ces enfants vont être
des futurs adultes et que l'impact des
violences est une évidence c'est combien
de personnes qui ont été accompagnés
depuis la création
alors nous avons depuis sa création
accueilli 2000 à peu près de 1400 femmes
et plus d'une cinquantaine d'enfants qui
sont soit des enfants qui sont des
enfants qu'aux victimes on va dire lent
des violences internes intrafamiliales
fois les soit les enfants de la zone
donc qui sont principalement victimes de
très graves violences sexuelles d'accord
le place et donc de fait on l'a dit les
missions de l'association la première
c'est déjà cet accompagnement auprès de
ces femmes et enfants victimes de
violence mais les missions sont
multiples et aussi un angle de formation
auprès des professionnels de santé se
soit tout à fait alors pourquoi on parle
de formation parce que je pense que
notre dispositif est extrêmement
innovant puisque en 2014 on a lancé à la
conception d'une forme de prise en
charge qui était indispensable
c'est la pluridisciplinarité et cette
formation et ses formations que nous
souhaitons effectivement dispensés que
l'on dispense déjà auprès des gendarmes
auprès de la police auprès de certaines
institutions les services sociaux sont
des formations qui sont indispensables
pour apprendre le comment travailler le
mieux travailler ensemble a dit lui
aussi de la sensibilisation qui est fait
par votre association tout à fait la
sensibilisation elle est essentielle
puisque on est dans la proche en fait de
la violence et de la problématique de la
violence comme un problème de santé
publique
c'est un des plus grands problèmes de
santé publique qui coûte cher à la
société et qui malheureusement est peu
est plutôt méconnu puisque quand on
parle de la violence
on prend les chiffres de la police les
dépôts de plainte et ça donne un chiffre
qui est déjà monstrueux mais on n'y voit
pas toutes ces femmes qui ne portent pas
plainte et donc la sensibilisation est
extrêmement importante qu'elle soit
auprès des médecins par exemple puisque
vous avez deux formes d' approche pour
la santé et la médecine c'est des
services hospitaliers mais là on est
déjà aux urgences la femme est souvent
déjà
blessé physiquement soit le médecin de
famille le médecin généraliste qui est
un acteur qui est un peu tout seul dans
son cabinet qui souvent n'aborde
peut-être pas la violence ne sachant pas
comment orienter les femmes qui sont
victimes sur la prise en charge sur le
fonctionnement de l'association vous le
dis c'est une prise en charge
pluridisciplinaire
on parle de santé mais aussi de l'aspect
juridique pourquoi c'est important
qu'ils aient cette prise en charge avec
qui englobe tous ces domaines alors je
pense que quand on a créé ce centre on
voulait en fait réunir deux univers qui
ne se parlent pas tant que ça
c'est la santé la justice sachant que
les médecins souvent produisent des
éléments factuels des dossiers on va
dire de constat de coups et on se
rendait compte que l'avocat ne savait
pas le réinterpréter parce que tous les
deux on était un peu prisonnier du
secret professionnel
ce que l'on a mis en avant dans cette
organisation c'est un secret partagé
donc il n'y a absolument pas de frein à
partager des éléments qui ne peuvent que
servir a finalement porté à un dossier à
la jeu vers la justice
après ça c'est une volonté que nous
avons de faire travailler les gens
ensemble ça marche extrêmement bien à
l'intérieur puisqu'on staff les
situations on se met autour de la table
on discute et on a une vraie stratégie
commune après il faut que l'extérieur
répondent aussi et je pense notamment au
dépôt de plainte qui ne sont
malheureusement pas assez souvent pris
en considération voire pris part on va
dire par peut-être méconnaissance du
sujet voire de ce qu'est une femme
victime de violence puisque souvent on
est dans un stress post traumatique qui
nous rend on va dire qui rend une
victime peut-être plus incohérente et
peut-être moins crédible auprès de la
police donc c'est important de dire que
tout ça nous le travaillons pour que l
soit écoutée en fait la mère elle veut
se parler est ce que c'est elle qui
viennent vers vous haussez plutôt du
signalement des témoins qui peuvent
assister à des violences le mot
signalement effectivement c'est un mot
qui est un peu un mot valise
je pense qu'aujourd'hui les acteurs qui
sont plus sensibilisés
à détecter sont absolument en capacité
aujourd'hui d'orienter d'orienter vers
un dispositif qui va répondre à une
problématique globale il faut toujours
savoir que quand on parle de global on
n'est pas simplement sur une forme de
violence déclaré
on remonte quand même dans la vie de la
personne et on se rend compte et c'est
là qu'on parlait des enfants que ces
personnes étaient souvent des enfants
qui n'ont jamais été pris en compte dans
on va dire un post traumatique d'une
situation qui a pu les ai donc ces
femmes se sont construite principalement
sur une vulnérabilité
cette analyse que l'on fait aujourd'hui
sur les enfants on le fait aussi sur les
jeunes puisqu'on est le dispositif du
harcèlement sexuel dans les universités
parisiennes et c'est intéressant de voir
que ces jeunes femmes viennent se saisir
d'un dispositif qui porte un nom
harcèlement sexuel mais très très
souvent il y a eu en virant point de
départ des enfants des étudiants qui ont
peut être on va dire témoins de
violences intrafamiliales et qu'ils se
sont créées ces dernières habilité on va
dire dans leur vie dans leur parcours de
vie
il reste une minute jeudi en début
d'entretien florence foresti et jonathan
cohen qui ont remporté pour votre
association 72 mille euros lors de qui
veut gagner des millions c'était le week
end dernier ses 72 mille euros ils vont
ils vont servir à financer deux des
actions à quoi bon si le servir je
voudrais déjà dire que vous vous êtes
rendu compte que notre marraine est
extrêmement engagée auprès de nous ce
qui est quand même assez rare parce que
on peut être marre un parrain ou
marraine d'une association sans pour
autant investir je renseigne un vrai
souci c'est de nous amener de l'argent
quelle que soit la forme que ça prend là
c'est un jeu mais elle a fait d'autres
actions donc on est très très fier de
son engagement
d'abord parce que ça répond à un manque
de financement
aujourd'hui la cause elle n'est pas
assez couverte par les moyens que
pourrait donner
on va dire les institutions voire la
politique les politiques
donc aujourd'hui c'est sous ce sont
entièrement dédiés en fait aux femmes
que nous recevons puisque nous n'avons
pas parlé de la proportion de bénévoles
et de salariés
on a deux tiers de bénévoles et un tiers
de
salariés ce qui veut dire que le
bénévolat prend une forte part dans
l'engagement des professionnels autour
des femmes que ce soit des médecins des
infirmières des masseurs des ostéopathes
tous ces gens là viennent donner de leur
temps pour l'association mais on a
énormément d'activités autour on a des
psychologues que nous payons donc il ya
énormément de frais de coûts la location
rien que du lieu donc tout est dédié à
la femme on a absolument pas de marc de
marge de manoeuvre je dirais en tout cas
peut-être vous aider donner à cette
association je vous invite à vous rendre
sur le site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran merci frédéric martin
être basée sur ce plateau cofondatrice
et directrice générale de cette
association ou bensaïd qui est basée à
saint germain en laye c'est l'heure du
portrait de la semaine
[Musique]
la tendance et merveilles et ravi les
papilles le cac design le but a réalisé
des gâteaux sur mesure et très créatif
aux clayes-sous-bois nohad hatoum a
remporté de nombreux prix en tant que
quelques designers la rencontre est
signée manon varaldo
un gâteau qui ne ressemble à aucun autre
une architecture des mesures et ciselé
avec parfois des visages très réaliste
voici le cake design la tendance
provient des états unis ce gâteau est
fait sur mesure pour des événements
précis baptêmes mariages ou encore baby
shower
derrière ses créations aux noah datum sa
particularité
la conception de fleurs davantage c'est
que vraiment on peut positionner les
pétales comme on veut peut fermer la
fleur on peut l'ouvrir réalisation
également de rose là quelques designers
façonnent les pétales une par une pour
donner du relief plus je rajoute deux
tours plus elle sera grosse et là en
fait faire à mesure la rose est en train
de prendre vie
ces fleurs agrémenteront de son gâteau
qu'elle réalise elle même j'ai préparé
deux gâteaux pour une petite pièce
montée et du coup là où on va attendre
un petit peu avant de les sortir pour
que je puisse préparer la pâte et les
recouvrir l'ingrédient qui fait toute la
différence la pâte à sucre partie
intégrante du cake design je tiens la
petite jupe ce qu'on appelle la petite
jupe
je fais simplement adhérer le gâteau
autour des créations qui lui ont valu
plusieurs prix noah datum a remporté la
médaille de bronze au concours sugar
paris 2018 l'unique salon du cac design
en france
autre prix gagné la médaille d'argent au
concours de cake internationale en
novembre 2018 à birmingham en angleterre
avec cette maison très réaliste c'est ma
fille qui m'a inspiré elle m'a donné une
idée à m'a dit maman
j'aime beaucoup la s'ils viennent à
family pourquoi tu ne ferais pas une
maison en silvana family pour mon
anniversaire
durant deux mois et demi la kek designer
a confectionné toutes les pièces de la
maison en sucre en pensant à tous les
détails à l'échelle près cette maman
s'est lancé dans le cake design il y a 6
ans depuis un an elle a créé sa société
mais la recette n'était pas tout tracé
pour noah datum c'est une reco
version pour cette quarantenaire j'ai
passé mon ca fait pâtisserie pour pour
en faire mon métier
parce qu'à la base c'était pas du tout
ça à la base j'étais dans le domaine
médical la kek designer au toit les
clients dans son atelier comme un
styliste afin de personnaliser le gâteau
pour celui ci prévue pour 40 personnes
compter deux jours de conception et un
prix allant de 250 à 300 euros
un amour du métier qu'elle partage
autour d'ateliers qu'elle anime
aujourd'hui on va travailler
lafleur donc le poinsettia la kek
designer transmet ses techniques et
connaissances aux seniors de l'espace
jacqueline auriol des clayes-sous-bois
vous prenez la baule en font légèrement
légèrement faut pas que ça traverse
d'autres cours sont également proposés à
son atelier l'année prochaine noah
d'atouts me remettra en compétition sa
médaille d'argent au concours de cake
international de birmingham et espère
viser la médaille d'or
si la fin de ce journal dans un instant
vos idées de sorties dans le satuc
loisirs belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]